a new video just released shows
employees robbed at a smoke shop this
happened at smoke smart shop over in the
southwest valley now tonight
surveillance video shows the robbers
cleaning out the register and shelves
while holding employees at gunpoint the
same business was targeted about three
years ago as well sally jaramillo is
live near flamingo and fort apache with
details of the latest armed robbery
there
christian this all happened right after
midnight at 12 23 a.m now two robbers
targeting this smokes mart shop right
here definitely the owners say they have
had enough
min fernley and his wife own smoke smart
they've been operating since 2015 since
their first experience dealing with an
armed robbery they've made changes we
added
additional cameras we got over 30
something cameras both inside and
outside they also installed a new crime
fighting tool dna security solutions
they spray the
invisible ink but today this wasn't
enough they were waiting outside so the
door was open when they when they came
in surveillance video shows what appears
to be two young men entering the store
pulling out a gun and taking money from
the registers pretty upset obviously of
what happened to you know our staff and
one of our customers that walked in
during the middle of the robbery fernley
says they are proud of their staff for
not escalating the situation there's
nothing in here that's worth anybody
getting hurt over so they did exactly
just that his message to the criminals
if you
commit a crime you will do the time and
as they get ready to expand next door
and open silver spoon cafe and lounge
they say they will be extremely prepared
back out live owners at smoke mart also
say police mentioned another robbery
nearby they are now considering hiring
armed security right here especially for
the midnight hours to protect their
employees and the people coming to visit
their shop for now reporting live sally
jaramillo live local now